Je ne sais pas quel ami youtubeur a oublié ses lunettes dans mon bureau! Mais en tout cas, elles sont très cool! *rire*
Voilà plutôt que d'envoyer vingt mille SMS, c'est plus simple si tu vois la vidéo! Viens les récupérer hein, elle sont là. Regarde. *bruit de casse*
Elles sont cassées maintenant.
Les amis, vous le savez, sur cette chaîne YouTube,
j'adore faire ce qui me plaît! Alors des fois, on fait des petits sketchs,
des fois on fait des vidéos impro, des fois c'est d'humour, des fois on regarde des vidéos et aujourd'hui je vais
parler d'un sujet qui me passionne, mon gars! On a tous un petit truc qui nous passionne dans la vie.
J'espère! Si c'est pas le cas, c'est juste que vous l'avez pas encore trouvé mais y a forcément des trucs qui vont vous passionner tôt ou tard!
Moi c'est.. L'ESPACE!
Et Red Dead Redemption 2 un peu, en ce moment. Mais sinon ça va.
Aujourd'hui j'ai trop envie d'en parler. Y a pleins de choses à apprendre autour de ce sujet!
Vous allez voir, c'est fascinant !
Et en plus, ça a jamais été autant d'actualité.
Parce que comme on est en train de n*quer littéralement la planète, enfin on est "en train" on l'a déjà
quasiment entièrement n*quée, il va falloir qu'on aille vers une autre planète!
On est comme ça nous! on n*que ce qu'on a, puis on va trouver un truc similaire et on va le niquer à son tour! C'est comme
ça! Je vais essentiellement vous parler de Mars, parce que c'est a priori la prochaine destination de
l'Humanité dans l'univers.
Je vais vous raconter un peu où on en est un petit peu dans l'astronomie,
Pourquoi ont veut allez sur mars, et face à quels problèmes-
faisons-nous face un problème dans cette phrase est présent trouver le pour aller sur cette fameuse planète rouge.
Connaissez-vous l'ISS?
l'International Space Station dont la construction a commencé à la fin des années 60, c'était une idée des soviétiques, les américains ont marché sur la Lune,
c'était incroyable et les soviétiques que se sont dit: "ok c'est bien marcher sur le satellite de la Terre..." Il faut savoir que la Lune, il n'y
a rien à y faire, il n'y a pas d'atmosphère c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'on voit qu'elle a des trous, elle se mange des tas
de météorites et d'objets qui passent dans l'Univers et elle n'abrite rien qui puisse nous aider,
ni oxygène, ni eau.
Bref rien n'est propice à la vie là-bas donc on a rien à y foutre. En tout cas de manière durable! l'ISS, les  soviétiques l'ont donc
conçue parce qu'ils voulaient vivre et travailler dans l'espace de manière durable! Et ils ont réussi, parce qu'elle est continuellement occupée depuis 1971.
C'est à dire qu'au moment où l'on parle il y a des gens qui sont là haut dans l'ISS et qui voient ce spectacle.
*musique*
Alors je me suis aperçu en parlant un peu de cette passion que j'ai autour de moi, que les gens ne savent pas pourquoi
l'ISS existe et ils savent encore moins ce que les astronautes font dans cette fameuse station. Et c'est vrai que quand tu t'intéresses pas
au sujet bah t'en sais rien et tu te doutes pas que ça a une quelconque utilité en fait qu'on fait là haut. Et pourtant mec! Et pourtant!
En gros, grâce à leurs expériences on apprend énormément de choses pour pouvoir mener à bien des voyages spatiaux longs.
Pourquoi des voyages spatiaux longs? parce que mars c'est loin sa mère!
En moyenne, Mars est à 70 millions de km de la terre. Ça veut dire que pour y aller faut qu'on fasse 70 putain de millions de
kilomètres! Et je vous dis ça parce que c'est un problème qui est au coeur des interrogations de la NASA de l'ESA et de l'Agence Russe.
La durée du trajet pour aller sur Mars, et pour revenir! Avec les systèmes de propulsion actuels, on mettrait six mois à atteindre Mars.
Mais comme les deux planètes bougent, le retour lui serait beaucoup plus long puisqu'il prendrait un an et trois mois.
*trois mois?!*
Et la mission elle sur mars durerait au final un mois. C'est à dire qu'il y a presque deux ans de voyage pour ne rester que
un mois sur place. Cette durée elle pose problème déjà pour une contrainte physique. On a évolué sur terre depuis toutes ces années on est soumis
à la gravité et le corps humain n'est pas fait pour survivre dans un milieu où il n'y a pas de gravité. Souvenez-vous vu que j'avais fait
un vol en 0G en plus je peux vous dire un peu ce que ça fait au corps, mais moi c'était des séries de 20 secondes,
eux ils y restent six mois donc c'est pas la même! L'oreille interne est complètement perdue donc pendant quelques jours on a la nausée puis après
le corps s'habitue. Et surtout la conséquence la plus importante d'être en 0G pendant un
long moment c'est la perte de masse musculaire et de masse osseuse et ça, ça fait chier parce que quand tu as fait six mois en 0G
et tu reviens en 1G sur Terre, bah ton corps mon gars se prend un
uppercut dans la gueule, il comprend plus ce qui lui arrive! Pour faciliter le retour des astronautes,
ils font donc du sport tous les jours pendant deux heures pour maintenir une certaine masse musculaire et osseuse pour que quand ils reviennent sur Terre,
qu'il puissent encaisser le choc! Et chose encore plus grave que la perte de masse musculaire et osseuse, c'est le vieillissement des parois artérielles!
Parce que comme t'es en 0G tous les fluides de ton corps remontent et en gros, le sang ne va plus dans tes jambes.
On considère que quand tu passes six mois dans l'espace, tes parois artérielles
ont vieilli environ autant que quelqu'un qui a passé de 30 ans sur Terre.
C'est abusé! Alors, rassurez vous pour nos chers astronautes, quand ils reviennent sur Terre, les parois se régénèrent et au final il n'y a aucune conséquence à long
terme de leur voyage dans l'espace. Mais si tu fais six mois en 0G, plus un mois en 0.36G,
plus quinze mois en 0G, on ne sait pas si c'est rattrapable le vieillissement des parois artérielles! Et on ne sait pas même si
tu vas pas crever en fait dans l'histoire tellement elles vont être endommagées ces parois! On est donc face à un premier problème.
Alors, il y a des solutions qui sont envisagées, en gros l'idée ce serait de recréer au sein du vaisseau la gravité qu'on a sur Terre.
Mais comment faire dans un vaisseau spatial pour recréer la gravité terrestre?
*voix avec de l'écho* La force centrifuge!
Excusez moi je chante, c'est que je suis très heureux de parler de ça, donc j'ai besoin de chanter.
On pourrait mettre une petite centrifugeuse dans le vaisseau qui permettrait de soumettre le corps du coup de l'astronaute, à une gravité plus ou moins proche de celle de la Terre
et donc que son corps ne se déshabitue pas complètement du milieu terrestre.
Bon bah du coup, on est bon, on peut aller sur mars!
*rire* Ah Si seulement! *En chantant*
Il faut savoir que sur Terre on a la chance d'avoir un atmosphère et donc un champ magnétique qui entoure la terre et qui nous
protège d'énormément de choses. Ça nous protège des météorites, des comètes, des éruptions solaires... Franchement on est bien sur Terre! Mais lors d'un voyage spatial,
surtout quand il dure six mois ou quinze mois pour le retour, on a plus d'atmosphère dans le vaisseau. On est fragile et on est
soumis à tout ce qui passe à travers l'espace. Y compris les tempêtes solaires et rayons cosmiques. et il y en  a beaucoup là-haut!
Tout ça c'est des radiations, les radiations vous connaissez, ça endommage ton ADN et ça entraîne des tumeurs des cancers etc. Bref ça réduirait
considérablement l'espérance de vie de nos astronautes!
Alors pour que le voyage se passe bien et que nos astronautes arrivent en pleine santé, faut se protéger de ça! Et actuellement ce qu'on connaît
pour se protéger des radiations c'est l'eau. Donc il faudrait mettre une couche de 2 à 3 mètres d'épaisseur tout autour du vaisseau remplie d'eau.
Ce qui est impossible! Ça pèserait je sais pas combien de kilos et on pourrait pas faire décoller la fusée.
Alors les scientifiques essayent de recréer un champ magnétique exactement comme celui qui nous protège
ici sur Terre sauf que là ce serait pour protéger le vaisseau, mais comment on fait pour produire ce champ magnétique là, j'en sais rien,
je ne suis pas scientifique!
Mais ils travaillent dessus et apparemment ils ont des pistes donc on pourrait réussir à faire ça, ce qui serait déjà une très grande avancée.
Un autre problème bien sûr c'est comment les astronautes vont ils pouvoir se nourrir, boire, respirer et évacuer leurs déchets?
La Station Spatiale Internationale se situe à 400 kilomètres au dessus de nous. Ce qui veut dire qu'on peut leur envoyer des
provisions assez facilement, c'est pas si loin. C'est même très proche en fait à l'échelle du Système Solaire. Je sais plus tous les combien de temps
mais je sais qu'on envoie un cargo aux astronautes qui sont dans l'ISS, dans lequel il y a de la nourriture, des vêtements...
Bref, des biens et des vivres pour qu'ils puissent survivre là-haut en fait. Une fois qu'ils ont vidé, ils le remplissent avec leurs déchets et
quand ce truc-là repart de la station, bah ils crame dans l'atmosphère et ça a permit aux astronautes de garder une station clean.
il faut quelques heures pour atteindre l'ISS, mais pour atteindre Mars,
on l'a dit il faut plusieurs mois! Les astronautes vont donc devoir survivre grâce à un écosystème, c'est à dire qu'ils vont devoir consommer tout
ce qu'ils créent. Donc, pour leur nourriture on va créer des tas de plantes ce qui va permettre en plus de créer de l'air, de
l'oxygène pour qu'il puisse respirer! Les déchets qu'ils produisent bah faut qu'ils soient recyclables pour qu'ils puissent fabriquer autre chose derrière avec, pour les outils
par exemple, plutôt que d'emmener des caisses et des caisses d'outils,
il y a une idée, c'était d'emmener une imprimante 3D qui leur permettrait d'imprimer l'outil dont ils ont besoin et de le faire fondre derrière
pour en fabriquer un autre quand ils ont besoin d'un autre outil. Une autre contrainte aussi à laquelle on pense pas forcément, c'est la contrainte
psychologique. On va mettre des gens dans un espace confiné pendant des mois. Et ces gens là vont devoir travailler en équipe pendant toute la
durée du voyage! C'est à dire que si il y a eu une embrouille tu vas pas faire la gueule dans un coin et ne rien faire pendant un mois,
ça ne marche pas ça! Sauf que l'humain n'est pas fait pour être collé à
d'autres humains dans un espace aussi petit pendant une longue période. Déjà pendant une courte période tu pètes un câble, pendant plusieurs mois je t'en
parle même pas! Il va donc falloir choisir minutieusement
qui on envoie sur Mars parce qu'il n'est pas question qu'un conflit éclate au sein du groupe. Surtout vu le prix que ça coûte de les envoyer sur Mars
et vu les enjeux! Si tout ça c'est gâché par une embrouille parce qu'un mec a pas fait la vaisselle c'est stupide!
En parlant de psychologie, une autre contrainte en fait c'est tout simplement le fait de se retrouver aussi loin de la Terre.
C'est à dire que tu es tellement loin de la terre que tu ne la vois même plus.
En fait les seuls humains à avoir perdu de vue la Terre, c'est ceux d'Apollo 11 quand ils ont dû faire le tour de
la Lune pour revenir sur Terre. Mais c'était vraiment sur une très courte durée on ne sait pas ce que ça peut provoquer chez un humain
de ne même plus voir la Terre! On a du mal à s'imaginer mais je pense que ça doit être terrible, tu dois vraiment
te dire: "Ok, chez moi c'est vraiment très très loin", c'est terrible.
Mais! N'oubliez pas! Il faut qu'ils fassent pousser des plantes pour pouvoir vivre donc ça leur rappellera un peu la Terre et ça leur fera je
pense beaucoup beaucoup de bien. Je pense que sans ça vraiment tu pètes un câble. Selon Thomas Pesquet, vu ce que c'est que d'aller sur Mars
c'est vraiment le plus gros truc que l'humanité fait de son histoire. C'est tellement
motivant pour l'équipage d'être les premiers à faire ça, aller sur Mars et c'est tellement un grand pas pour l'histoire de l'humanité que,
au final perdre la Terre de vue, c'est pas tant un problème que ça. Moi je ne veux pas la perdre de vue, je vous le
dis, je veux pas! Et enfin un autre gros gros gros problème c'est l'atterrissage sur Mars!
L'atmosphère de Mars est très très très fine donc pour atterrir quand t'ouvres ton parachute ça te freine beaucoup moins que quand t'ouvres un parachute sur Terre.
Sauf que là tu as 30 tonnes qui arrive à la vitesse de 5 ou 6 km par seconde! Pour les arrêter mon gars faut y aller!
Le Soyouz par exemple, le véhicule qui amène et ramène les astronautes de la Station Spatiale Internationale
À l'avant, il y a un gros bouclier thermique qui, en fait, crame à la place du vaisseau lorsqu'il rentre dans l'atmosphère. Sur Mars c'est pareil,
alors, elle est plus fine l'atmosphère mais elle est quand même là. Et on arrive tellement vite que ça brûle très fort! D'après les estimations,
faudrait un bouclier thermique qui fasse 25 mètres de diamètre!
Sauf que, pareil! C'est beaucoup trop gros et lourd pour être amené dans l'espace et le bouclier même si il freinerait beaucoup le vaisseau, il suffirait pas,
faudrait ensuite déployer un
parachute sauf que comme l'air est très fin, faudrait que le parachute fasse la taille d'un stade de foot! Et c'est pas tout! Même après ça on
est encore à 2000 km heure donc il faut des fusées qui poussent dans l'autre sens pour freiner le vaisseau quoi.
C'est compliqué! Alors, ce qui est encourageant c'est qu'on a déjà réussi à envoyer des sondes sur Mars, il y en a plusieurs à l'heure où
on parle et ils prévoient encore d'en envoyer. Et, globalement, il y a que un
atterrissage sur trois qui échoue, ce qui est plutôt encourageant en fait. Alors pourquoi on veut aller vers Mars et pas une autre planète? Parce que
Mars, par le passé, a eu des similitudes avec la Terre, comme par exemple ne serait-ce que la présence d'eau
nécessaire à toute forme de vie! On peut trouver sur Mars des traces de lacs! Et c'est très encourageant!
Mars a aussi une atmosphère, une fine atmosphère, bon, pas du tout comme celle de la Terre mais quand même ça, reste un point commun
entre les deux planètes et il y a pas beaucoup de planètes qui ont un atmosphère et des tas d'autres trucs que je sais pas mais demandez aux scientifiques
et ils vous diront *rire* merde!
Non, mais voilà en gros, c'est la planète sur laquelle on met un peu nos espoirs parce que voilà, elle présente des trucs communs avec
la Terre. Alors même si il y a rien de vivant sur Mars, il y avait rien de vivant aussi il y a très longtemps sur Terre et pourtant la
vie est apparue. Alors peut-être que Mars va nous permettre de comprendre comment la vie est apparue sur Terre, comment on est passé de la
matière inerte à quelque chose de vivant! Les amis, il y a trop de problèmes là dans cette vidéo, ça fait chier! Mais c'est ça qui
est intéressant, c'est de savoir pourquoi on n'est pas encore sur Mars, pourquoi il n'y a pas encore une colonie d'humains là bas... Bref on a
beaucoup de bâtons dans les roues mais, à priori, les premiers humains partiraient en direction de Mars dans les années vers genre
2025. À priori! D'après les gens les plus ambitieux. comme vous voyez, il y a encore beaucoup de problèmes à résoudre et 2025 c'est demain! J'ai énuméré
les plus gros problèmes et il y en a beaucoup d'autres, je suis pas scientifique de toute manière donc il y à plein de trucs que j'ai dû
oublier ou quoi... Si il y en a qui veulent apporter des précisions dans les commentaires, bah hésitez pas, j'espère que vous avez passé un bon moment,
même si ça vous fait pas plus kiffer que ça, l'espace, bah j'espère que vous aurez appris des trucs et que vous
trouvez ça un peu plus intéressant désormais. Voilà, en tout cas, j'en aurais parlé, donc je suis très content! Si vous voulez faire partie des
premiers à aller sur Mars n'hésitez pas, il y a un lien dans la description pour postuler... C'est entièrement faux! *rire*
J'aimerais bien, mais c'est faux, on peut pas! Envoyons plutôt de la force à Thomas Pesquet, qui, ça se trouve, fera partie des premiers
à aller sur mars putain! Je vous fais des bisous, comme d'habitude, je vous dis à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo et puis voilà portez vous bien!
Allez hop! Je vais moins loin que sur mars parce que je vais chez moi! Voilà, c'est à cinq kilomètres ça va!
Merci encore d'avoir lu les sous-titres!
*musique*